when I was a kid again there were five
of us and and we would go for walks a
long long deserted logging roads that
wound their way into the hemlock forest
that surrounded Aberdeen and we would
imagine that we were pioneers explorers
that were the first humans that had ever
been on these roads at contradiction in
terms I suppose but you know I've always
sort of wanted to be an explorer and
when I went to Cornell Bob Richardson
gave it a talk on a new refrigeration
technology that gave the promise of
allowing man to look at nature in a new
and different realm and I wanted to be
with people and that was what I decided
I would go into low temperature physics
so so I I went in with the idea that
there would be some excitement
associated with it and everything but my
fifth year graduate study the experiment
I was doing turned out it was based on
some very what appeared to be very
exciting work by by one of our
competitors and when I went into to
first reproduce that then go beyond it
we found it that that work was all wrong
and that the actual effect was was
easily calculated and I kept looking for
small deviations from the existing
theory and and it what I like to say is
if I'd continued on that experiment I
probably would be a taxicab driver New
York City or something like that but
luckily one day there were two other
students that had patiently been waiting
for the only NMR iron core electromagnet
in the lab so high enough homogeneity
and stability to do in tomorrow and
eventually they went to dave lee and bob
richardson and they sort of agreed that
i had to relinquish this magnet which
i'd been monopolizing for three months
and so it was only after that that I did
a curiosity driven experiment which in
fact gave the first ever
that we'd seen and a new phase
transition now we were the refrigeration
technology was a mixture of liquid and
solid healing 3 and we didn't know
whether the phase transition that that
this curve that we saw was giving
evidence I was in the liquid or the
solid and the first publication we made
we were wrong I mean all the data was
was correct but but the interpretation
was all wrong we'd said it was all in
this the solid and and but it wasn't and
but you know I wasn't you know I this
was exactly what I felt I'd been born
for and I wasn't going to just stop so I
kept trying to come up with better and
better ways of probing what was going on
inside this this mixture at this very
very low temperature where one couldn't
see what was happening it took a few yes
until you got the price and you moved on
only a few years it took 24 or something
like that yes